Now there is another fundamental question which is,
uh,
what makes the difference between different materials.
And the,
the other question is how do we model well,
different materials reflecting,
coming,
right,
two different directions and they absorb different amounts of it in different
waivers.
Uh,
that's the answer we are,
we are going to talk a lot about this,
but this is an example.
These are different material.
So the specular,
uh,
in the specular case there is one incoming direction and there is one possible
outcome in direction.
That's it.
This is what always happened.
This is for instance,
a mirror because I see exactly the reflection of myself.
There's,
there's no,
no other thing that I see in the mirror.
But for a diffuse surface,
for one incoming direction,
there's many possible outcomes in many possible directions.
And this gives a diffuse surface.
We are going to see examples of depth and it writes,
it writes spread.
Please forget this term.
Let's call this whole single step because this is what it is.
This is like the mixture of these two.
So these are some basic material models that we are going to see in our
renderers later on.
Uh,
now to formalize this in a way,
let's create a function that's a probability density function with three
parameters.
So this is a three dimensional function.
Uh,
one variable is the incoming light direction.
The other variable is a point on the surface.
And what I'm interested in is how much light is flowing out from this point in
different directions.
Now,
uh,
a bit more formalized this Fr is going to be disruption.
I'm interested in the income and direction and the point in space.
This is,
this too,
is what I have and I will be interested in the outgoing directions.
What is the probability of different outcomes,
directions,
and this is how we will,
how we will write it formally.
Omega is an incoming direction.
Direction x is a point in space that we choose.
And Omega prime is the outgoing direction.
And this we call the BRDF for,
uh,
bi-directional reflectors,
distribution functions.
So this is a very complicated name for something that's very simple.
The RDF.
Now,
uh,
what about materials that don't reflect all incoming light?
There are some materials that transmit some of it.
So for instance,
glass,
water,
uh,
gemstones and such,
but it's,
it could look like that.
And here above you can see some brds and below you can say some some things
because it's not reflected.
It's transmitted.
There are some materials that let them feel.
So here's an example.
While everyone had seen windows and things like that,
uh,
well the question is why?
Like just a physical question.
Why are these objects,
France,
Paris,
sorry.
Yes.
They to the lipid.
What is happening here?
Exactly.
So just some,
uh,
physical intricacy that
did the most fundamental question.
You know,
what is inside of an APP?
And the best answer is nothing because an atom is 99% empty space.
There is the nucleus,
which is,
uh,
the whole anthem is the size,
for instance,
of a football field.
If you imagined that,
that the nucleus is a small piece of rice in the middle of the football field,
that's the nucleus.
And the electrons are also very small.
Things like small rises,
which are orbiting dislocate lists from very far away like the side sides of the
football field and in between there's nothing,
absolutely nothing.
So the more interesting question would be why is not everything transparent?
I mean,
there's absolutely nothing in there that would divert that or absorb delight,
right?
Everything,
just everything should go through.
Why is not everything transparent,
not only us but everything.
And the reason is uh,
absorption.
So these electrons are orbiting the nucleus.
And what essentially is happening is that electrons,
Kendo Sword,
four months,
four months are if you imagine a life as master raise or not waves,
but particles,
then following is the basic particle of light.
So electrons,
steak,
absorb photons.
And if they do,
they go from an owner or a bit like a lower energy level,
they jump to a higher energy level because it's,
it's basically you after lunch,
you eat something,
you get more energetic,
you get,
you get more jumpy.
So it jumps to an outer orbit,
uh,
from the nucleus.
It's a bit further away.
So it's,
it's sourced the light so the light doesn't go through.
So this is why most things are not transparent.
But the question is why is stem glass transparent?
And the answer is that these Barbie's is different.
Uh,
places around the nucleus.
They are so far apart that in the visible light spectrum,
if the electrons to absorb it for them,
they don't get enough energy to jump to the next orbit.
And this is why all this is why most of the light is going through this last
materials.
And
this is not always the case is the case for visible light spectrum.
There is a matter of spectrum which is absorbed.
So if you have a spectrum,
that gift that is a higher energy spectrum that it may give enough energy for
this electron to jump to a different orbit.
And uh,
we can easily find out,
uh,
what spectrum it is because for instance,
we use glass for a number of different beneficial things.
Well,
for instance,
you cannot get sunburn if you are inside of the house and you have your windows
closed and we are wearing sunglasses in order to protect our eyes from
something.
So,
uh,
is there someone who tells me what this spectrum is that exactly,
just a bit louder.
Ultraviolet.
Exactly.
Sahil Trevalla is a heart as a spectrum with a higher amount of energy is,
uh,
and,
and if you absorb it,
then this job is possible.
So this is why it is absorbed.
So just some physical intricacies.
So,
uh,
lights may get reflected if we have a material that most of the time reflects
light and we call it the BRDF.
The art is,
the interesting part is to reflection.
And if it transmit on is possible with the material model,
we have the BTDF,
which is divided reaction of transmittance distribution function.
And uh,
as an umbrella term for both of these,
this is basically the,
whatever term is BSDF.
So by direction of scattering distribution function,
I'm not saying this because this is lots of fun.
I'm saying this because you're going to find this,
these terms in the literature all the time.
So BSDF is basically things that reflect and things that transmit,
okay,
what other properties of brds.
And after this week,
we'll suddenly put together something beautiful very rapidly.
So there's townhalls.
Reciprocity means that their direction of the Ray of light can be reversed.
When it means mathematically is that I can swap the incoming and outgoing
directions and I'm going to get the same probabilities.
So the probability of going here to there is the same probability as coming from
there to here.
If I look at things,
uh,
from both sides,
I will get the same problem.
So that's,
that's often useful.
Uh,
in physics positivity,
this is a suffix.
We're not dory.
Well,
uh,
it cannot be less than zero are probably the two cannot be less than zero.
For every outgoing direction there is some positive probability or their zero.
That's it.
Nothing else is really possible.
So formula,
this is how it looks like and it makes some met in additions awfully happy
and there's energy conservation.
The most important property,
uh,
an object may reflect or absorb incoming light,
but it is impossible that more is coming out.
And the incoming amount,
well,
obviously we have light sources and things like that,
but we are talking about sweet material and models.
Uh,
so this means that if I integrate this function for all possible incoming
directions,
uh,
then I get,
if I take into consideration light attenuation that we have talked about this,
this,
uh,
why it is so hot,
noon and why it is so cold at night,
then I'm going to get one or less.
And this is because if you take most one,
and this means that this kind of material,
uh,
reflects all the light that comes in and if it's less than one than this means
that some of the flights is absorbed.
Okay?
We are almost there at the rendering equation.
Generally what we are going to do is that we pick a point x and this direction
is going to point towards the camera.
Or my eye is just basically means the same thing.
It's just an obstruction.
And what I'm going to be doing is I'm going to sum up all the possible incoming
directions where light can come to this point.
And I've interested in how much has it impacted towards my direction.
And let's not forget that objects can emit light themselves.
Okay?
And we will also compute this refracted amount of fluff.
So,
uh,
just intuition,
light exiting the surface towards my eye is the amount that it is itself.
It's a light source and the amount that it reflects from the incoming light that
comes from is zero things.
And this is how we can formally write this with this beautiful uh,
integral equation.
Let's see,
let's tear it a Sandler and see what happens.
Well this is the amount of light.
So this is light from point going towards my eye,
how much it did while the amounts that is in point x and knitted towards my,
if it's a light source like that one,
then I definitely have this amount and there is an amount,
the barrier flat that that is reflected.
Let's see what's going on.
It says what I just told you and again,
and this is the integration,
this is the interesting part.
So I am in integrating this Omega prime,
so all possible incoming directions.
What you have seen the hemisphere on the previous image hemisphere means
basically halls,
one half of a sphere.
We are integrating go her hemisphere,
not over here,
not over a full sphere because if we're taking into consideration the co sign,
if the light comes from the bath that's cosigned,
zero degrees is one.
And as I rotate this light source around this point,
then this code sign we'll get to the 90 degrees.
So from here to there and the cosign of 90 degrees is zero.
Therefore it is going to be no throughput if it comes from that direction.
And if I have something that's higher that would be negative.
We don't deal with these cases.
So this is why I'm integrating over a hemisphere.
So sunlight is coming to this point in different directions.
And what I'm interesting in interested in is how much is this of this light is
reflecting towards my app.
This is multiplied by,
uh,
the incoming radiance.
There is the BRDF and light attenuation.
That's it.
Uh,
this is still a bit difficult.
This is still a bit and do safe.
So first we are going to train ourselves like bodybuilders on smaller weights.
So we are going to create it an easier version of this.
Uh,
because apparently this is terribly difficult to solve.
If you take a look and if you would sit down and try to solve it for a difficult
scene where you have objects and geometries and and different brds different
material models,
you will find that this is impossible to solve analogy.
Cool.
And one of the first problems is yes,
this is the question is just for one point.
So we are looking at one point and then you want to exactly.
Yes.
And and here it comes to cash.
So I'm interested in how much light is going towards my iPhone.
This point,
how much is it?
Well it depends.
If I turn on,
I don't light sources,
then this point is going to be brighter because the radiance coming out of this
point depends on its surroundings.
Is the window open?
Are The curtains pulled or an office.
So x,
this point x depends on this other point why for instance,
all other points.
Then we can say,
okay,
let's not compute this x first.
Let's compute this y point in steps first.
Because then I will do x.
Okay?
But this why also depends on x because how bright light is on the other side of
the room also depends on how bright it is in this side of the,
so there is some uh,
recurrent there and it's if you,
if you don't think out of the box,
this is impossible to solve because you don't know where to start.
Okay.
This integral is hopeless to compute enclosed form because there may be shapes
and different objects in there and this will make integration in mass and
difficult.
Okay?
Integral is in financial law.
Later you will see that if I compute one bounce,
this x that I have been talking about,
that's okay,
but I need to compute multiple bounces.
I need to start tracing race from the camera and see how much light is entering
the lens of the camera.
That one balance is not enough.
Is Two pounds is enough.
So after the x,
I can I continue somewhere else?
Is this enough?
Say something.
Okay.
But I think maybe three is a half is three enough?
It's not enough.
Okay.
Well you guys are very picky.
Uh,
is it bounces enough?
Okay.
Why not?
Because there's still some amount of energy laughed that if I would continue
this life path,
I would encounter other objects.
I don't have any knowledge of that.
We need to compute an infinite amount of bounces.
Even the 1000 is not else.
So,
and this render in the equation is going to be 1.1 and if I want to compute the
second bounce that's going to be embedded,
there's going to be embedded in another integral equation on other rendering the
equation.
And this goes on infinitely.
This is the biggest equation in the whole university.
It's impossible to solve and it is often singular.
I knew later show you why.
So even if you would want to integrate it,
you could.
So,
uh,
this is far too difficult.
It seems impossible.
And the Pantry at this point,
we cannot solve it.
So this is the end of the course and we have an impossible problem.
There is no reason even to try and goodbye.
See you.
Never,
because there's never going to be any more lectures back in order to understand
what's going on.
Uh,
firstly we're going to put together a simpler version of this equation that we
can understand and we can work our way up.
Uh,
there,
there is another formulation of the render in the question.
I'm not going to deal with this too much.
Uh,
you can imagine this other version as moving points around.
So,
uh,
there is a light source and beef meat and there is the sensor at p zero.
And this is one example life path.
And what I'm doing is I'm not stopping at one point and integrating all possible
in coming directions because this is what I did with the original formulation.
What I do is I compared to one life path,
I compute how much light is going through.
I add that to the sensor and then I moved this p two around,
I move into up bit,
I computer new like that.
How much is going to move this Peter around again?
So imagine this movie everywhere and imagine also p one movie and we were,
so all of these points are moving everywhere and I compute the contribution of
this light source to the sensor.
So this is another kind of integration.
I'm not going to go through this.
Uh,
what is interesting is that there is a geometry in there,
and,
uh,
this describes the geometry to relation of different points of light attenuation
between them.
Uh,
I'm not going to deal with this too much.
I just put it here because,
uh,
if you're interested then true your way through it.
And in literature,
they often write it this way.